welcome to this video Michael Hennigan
Michael H yeah i'm going to go afore i
will vary my openings a little bit more
no good I mean I'm mostly d4 Knight f3
kind of player but in in earlier videos
let's say a couple of month ago I was
playing a little bit more before but now
I've decided to do to do the same again
so just varying a little bit more recent
month I concentrated very much on on my
normal openings let's aim okay the early
b6 is there some way to exploit that
with the bishop f3 maybe Ben Bishop e3 I
think I don't know if this is such a
great great move order f5 might be might
be a tricky thing okay let's say that's
a funny regrouping huh but how to
exploit that the only big drawback is
that let's let's play the move first
save some time is that the night does
not have d7 as its natural retreat
square so I'm trying for this aggressive
move threatening g5 pushing him back of
course combining g4 and and and a 4 it's
a bit it's a bit risky maybe but well
it's got nothing out nothing developed
so maybe interesting not totally sure
how good it is but it definitely needs
an interesting game
yeah g5 maybe I don't know what you
should do actually g5 is is really
really a problem yeah Black has to do
something something special now I am a
normal move doesn't cut it like we
should be 75 then I've got g6 coming
this is especially problematic with the
rook on g7 se6 is not protected I
understand his time out it's it's not
easy at all to find a movie at all yeah
this is what I was thinking maybe look
see three or something I'm oh yeah okay
let's do this first light d to e to also
what's interesting he's saying hmm yeah
I understand this is it looks it looks
very very problematic okay so i have g6
as a move or I can also what about 96
for Bishop h5 check it's also rather
dangerous right 96 takes Bishop h5 check
king is seven well that looks like that
looks really really bad okay g6 first
he's got 95 and it's sort of holds oh so
96 takes bishop HR checking is seven
but I don't see I don't see a direct
direct kill them really toned ok let's
go g6 I could have played this could
have played this quicker then I could
have I should have played this quicker
it's the right expression this is the
normal move let's aim ok you cannot take
it because 96 wins wins flat out many
Bishop H fire for the move ok well now
it's too late ok no worries after Luke
f7 I go Bishop e2 and then F for next
and Queen d2 where this is just just an
attack I think
in our bishop age 5 he had g6 this
wasn't helping but I'm threatening now
f4 f4 and f5 yeah maybe I find f5 is
even the most powerful way to play not
even bothering with castling maybe okay
so f4 is going to take on h4 with a
check okay that's not very nice King on
d to where is a bit it's a bit a bit
vulnerable so yeah okay let's play at
rife kind of keep it simple move now
going from going for long castles it's
quite funny that he has doubled on the f
are now with this rook a7 d7 a7 d7 f7
maneuver now this is a good news
actually hmm i didn't i didn't take that
into account
yeah hmm not good no I'm getting Queens
traded is bad I mean bad relatively
speaking okay didn't know that that
wasn't that wasn't the best course of
events really wasn't
with this bad King and everything I
probably missed something but then it's
still still a pretty good position I
think you've got those d66 weaknesses
and so on f3 is weak but I don't really
see what you should do knight c6 maybe
980 c6 trying to challenge my D for
night ok going to take it and long
catalogs was my idea I wonder if it
makes sense to play rook g1 making sure
that I get get the g5 porn I'm not sure
well I want to take g6 ok mighty high
fatigue here at the end of age 6 mmm
yeah I kind of hoped for more but maybe
there is not nothing more available
simply
Brooke to have seven what now is there
is there anything great here he's a
little bit tied down maybe just activate
the king I would like to get the 94 to
attack those to attack the two
weaknesses and don't see how to do that
really
it's really not that's not too great
check e five Kings before he gives up
the square ok so what now before I five
maybe maybe I don't know ok let's see
that I get him on the on the light
squares check and stupid what did i do
here nah that was really really stupid
check check check check check Roger
Alford yeah I deserved that I really
deserved that spoiling a winning
position a couple of times even the end
game is clearly better for white I think
but ok I want to i want to check how I
could have won this in the opening
because this is pretty much pretty much
clear that white was what was was
winning you somehow so let's let's see
whoopsie 75 so what is winning actually
96 does win yeah I had the hunch that it
should win but I didn't see I didn't see
how to continue here Bishop we're
forever is strong yeah this is this is a
disaster yeah probably
maybe this isn't so clear huh hard to
say how to say I'm if this is this is
completely winning or not would be seven
maybe I don't know hey yeah that that's
curious how this opening but maybe can
be I'm okay here i just have to play
differently yeah maybe bishop yeah maybe
this is right the computer wants to go
bishop age five i was thinking that g6
yeah but it isn't a useful move right
when i get in Queen d2 i'm attacking
here and this is a huge difference if he
now plays Bishop yourself nagging Queen
d2 and age 6 s this vulnerable pawn and
fantastic provide I mean look at this
hit the pot structure it's got this this
crazy crazy bone structure ads it's
almost a winner with a stock fish giving
1.6 m and it's it's really strong and
here the big issue is that i didn't
really appreciate this Bishop g5 idea he
gets the gets the greens off it's still
a bit better due to the structure but it
is it is not comparable to what I had
before yeah the question is however is
there something better here of course I
can just take here Jackyl didn't I do
that now the successor it's not
defendable that's very nice hard also
win mmm okay I was thinking that this is
a good end game which is probably true
but check it is not as good as soon as I
wanted yeah and he has this idea that
was a bad play
ya can guarantee i'm fighting fighting
for the draw of course this is a very
stupid move I was very irritated by the
by this moment I have to go here of
course and prevent the King from
approaching can I do something in this
position probably not now and I can
place afore at some point but not
helping oh yeah I'm so at the beginning
I had chances but not at the end ok well
thanks for watching